how companies use data is a critical
part of their success
and the people who can harness the power
of data to drive insights
will be highly valued by companies of
all sizes in almost every industry
thanks to tools like power bi the skills
to collect
clean analyze and visualize data are
well within reach for
any professional looking to gain a
competitive edge
power bi is a powerful way to make sense
of data
draw in your audience and help
businesses make better decisions with
visualizations that yield actionable
insights
that's why udacity has partnered with
leading experts to create the data
analysis
and visualization with power bi
nanodegree program
this program will teach you to develop
in-demand skills in data pre-processing
visualization and analysis using power
bi
as the primary tool you'll learn to
utilize power bi to process
and transform data build compelling data
visualizations that tell a story
and create dashboards that help
businesses draw the insights needed to
make critical decisions
by the end of this program you will have
created a portfolio of real world
projects to show your skills with power
bi
learn to look at data in a different way
and lead key business decisions
enroll in udacity's data analysis and
visualization with power bi nano degree
program today